now you also have American Horror Story
coming up where you're playing your your
coven and your murder house character
what was filming that like and do the
two characters interact it off that's
true I am playing both those foreign
characters have not interacted coming
back to the murder house I have to say
it was good it I was nervous about it I
didn't know how you know how it was
gonna feel but then once we started to
fill me in hey you know I get back in
the wards I'll get back in the clothes
all of a sudden a little violet comes
out you have to kind of go back and
forth between the two is that it yeah
because the Wardrobe in there and the
set pieces are so different from each
other and that is it's easy to
differentiate the two worlds you know I
saw none you know a lot of people might
assume but your sister had something to
do with you getting the part but I had
heard that actually almost worked
against you can you walk us through that
casting process sure I mean you know
from my end I get the script I see that
it says it's been on the conjuring films
I kind of figure alright that's probably
not gonna help me but I let that go read
this middle of it I want to go audition
I do the job and I leave it there I
don't think about it again for a month
and then I get the call that I got the
job it's not so we're filming out here
from chlorine that they really did not
want to cast me because of who my sister
was because of my last name but I got
the job so I think I think I did
something right and you're on set being
like Oh didn't wanna corn
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]